I watched um Yuri banov I feel like he
must be he must be psychic or something
because what he describes in terms of
ideological subversion and how to
control basically an entire Generation
by going through academics and teaching
them at a young age how to think what to
think more specifically and how to then
get people to a place where they can't
agree on what objective reality is
that's essentially what's happening on
University campuses for myself having
come through Academia realizing that I
wouldn't be able to stay there and do
legitimate research anymore why don't I
just do my own research and do it this
way and not have to be con constrained
by a particular way of thinking or
knowing I have to find certain things
with my research in order for it to be
published back then I'm sure people were
like come on this is nonsense this is
not but if you look at it now in 2023
like he was telling the truth it's not
that he was psychic it's not that he
could see the future he understood the
methods that the KGB and that the
Soviets were using and have been using
in America now for at least 3 four
decades